we've now seen a couple of examples of
balancing chemical equations and we've
you've seen that okay
let's say we're trying to balance this
this equation right over here and we
started with the carbons i have two
carbons on the reactant side they're
both sitting in this ethylene molecule
and so i would want two carbons on the
product side and right now i only have
one carbon on the product side and so
what we've done is let's just put a two
out front here and so now we have two
for every for every molecule of ethylene
and we're not done balancing this
chemical equation yet we're now
producing two molecules of carbon
dioxide but one thing that you might
have been thinking oh why why put this
big two out front of the entire carbon
dioxide i like the way these little
subscript little twos look so why not
put a 2
why not put a 2 right over there and the
reason why you can't do that is that's
actually changing the molecule it's no
longer carbon dioxide it's now this
bizarre thing that doesn't really exist
in in
in nature which is the
c202 thing you're actually changing the
reaction when you're doing that when
you're balancing chemical reactions the
reaction itself is is even before it's
balanced it's describing something that
happens it's just
when it's unbalanced it just doesn't
have the numbers of right it doesn't
have the numbers right in terms of
number of molecules so the only thing
that you can change when you're changing
these is the number of molecules you
can't con you can't change the number of
constituents within a molecule and
that's why we do not change these
subscripts and if you want to visualize
it a little bit differently
let's draw each of these
each of these molecules so ethylene
looks like this so double bond with the
carbons
and then each carbon is bonded to two
hydrogens
notice you have two carbons and four
molecular oxygen o2
looks like this it's oxygen
double bonded to oxygen
and then
you have
carbon dioxide carbon dioxide
is a carbon
double bonded
to two oxygens each and then finally you
have water
finally water
actually let me do this in a different
color
your water right over here this is an
oxygen bonded to two hydrogens so let me
write the plus signs there
so plus this right over there so if you
were to if you were to somehow
write a subscript of two right over
there you would you'd somehow be
changing the structure you would be
changing what this molecule is as
opposed to that which we don't want to
do we want to say okay we're definitely
producing carbon dioxide we're
definitely producing carbon dioxide but
how many carbon dioxide do we produce
for each for each molecule of ethylene
and so that's where we say okay we have
two carbons here we want two carbons
here we don't want to change the actual
structure here so let's write the two
out front so we're going to have two
of these or if you want to do if you
want to
have it more visual you could write okay
we're just going to have another
molecule here
we're just going to have a another
molecule so now we've balanced the
carbons two carbons on the product on
the reactant side two carbons on the
product side and then you go to the
hydrogens you see okay we have four
hydrogens here we only have two here
well what if we had two of these water
molecules so let's let's draw another
water molecule here
so o
h and actually let me write this right
over here so now we have two of these
and now we have
we have two of these and now we want to
balance the oxygens so we see on this
side we have two oxygens on this side we
have one two three four five six oxygens
so what if so in order to balance or
have six oxygens on the reactant side we
need three of these molecules
so
another one
and another one
right over there and now we're all
balanced we have two carbon atoms on
both sides carbons carbons we have we
have four hydrogen atoms on both sides
here they're in the ethylene here
they're in the waters and then we have
six oxygen atoms on both sides and here
they're there some of the oxygens are in
the carbon dioxides some of them are in
the waters and here they're all in the
molecular oxygens but notice we didn't
change the actual structure of the of
the molecules we just changed the number
of molecules we have and that's what
these these coefficients in front of in
front of these these molecular formulas
represent